hello YouTube Ian's I'm Dave Rubin this
is the Rubin report I've got a challenge
Scott I've got desi joy and I've got
Adam hunter who just threw his phone for
some reason I don't know why we have a
tremendous show for you and we got to
get right to it because this is the
Internet and you're a busy person so
we're to start with everybody's favorite
crotchety old man John McCain now as
everybody knows Rand Paul did something
that I think was pretty spectacular he
did a 13-hour filibuster basically
saying that Americans shouldn't be
killed on American soil without due
process you know that seems pretty fair
and then mr. old man John McCain this
week called him a wacko bird for
something that's pretty patriotic in my
opinion where do we start with this is
John McCain just lost his mind
hey John Scott I think he has a great
sponsorship deal with Angry Birds that's
why he called they're wacko Birds and I
think there's some sort of corporate
deal Republicans are known for that you
know there's some sort of involvement
there so you think he's getting
something other back and he's just an
angry old man who can't spend 13 hours
wait listening to brand Paul be stupid I
would actually like to see him upgrade
and maybe you know update his curse
words and the things that he says a
wacko Birds come up with that yeah what
do you think of this idea though that
he's mocking what in my opinion was the
best thing Republicans have done in in
five years problems I think he would be
against that because you know Rand Paul
is making a lot of money fundraising off
of this so first of all he's making the
money and he's getting all you know the
young kids all excited about it and it
highlights the civil war that's going on
in the Republican Party right now and
the old-school guys who are you know
they're okay with the other civil
liberties violations that we've been
doing overseas it's just you know in
this one area they're not happy with it
so I think it's a major point of
hypocrite apocrypha with them as well as
you are you are new school what do you
think about this I think that McCain
calling someone a whacko bird is like
lohan Collins when a hot mess Octomom
saying you're a bad parent yeah it isn't
really he does have to update his
references and I think he I think what
happened was during the filibuster he
felt like he was trapped and it brought
him back to his days in Vietnam
he couldn't actually get out he just
felt like he was you couldn't honestly
like literally I'm with McCain on this
one it's yeah Rand Paul 13 hours it
wasn't a necessary filibuster do you do
not Allah Buster for you know expanding
into more universal health care for
Obamacare I want a Democrat to do that I
don't want Rand Paul talking about drugs
so left he makes the Young Turks people
look right that was the most left I want
to a realistic reason to stand there
into a filibuster what what you know you
know Jim mr. Smith goes to Washington
did that's what I want for something
good not for drones attacking New York
City that didn't even happen
Rand Paul planted his flag the return of
the talking filibuster you know last
year Bernie Sanders senator from Vermont
and independent he also did a still a
talking filibuster that was so
beautifully written that it was
published as a book we don't talk about
that we didn't really hear about that it
wouldn't didn't really get pushed
throughout the media but this filibuster
that Rand Paul did again of which he's
raising a lot of money off of you know
that is something that we hear about so
I finally if there's a there's a big
disconnect with the things that the
corporate media focuses on and that the
regular public hears about versus you
know what's actually going right Twitter
all right so you I can see clearly not a
fan of this of the concept that Rand
Paul went with do you to start with you
does he do you believe in what Rand Paul
was doing just the bay if we were to
forget the politics and what you think
about him related to abortion or women's
rights and gay people and all that do
you think that the filibuster in and of
itself was the right thing to do I think
it was an excellent thing to do because
it actually did get that national
conversation going God knows we could
use a lot more national conversations
about a lot more subjects but at least
on this one thing we're talking about it
and it's really important because at
this point we're also talking about the
ability of future presidents you know
some people who would say oh well it's
Obama so it's oh I'm okay with that I'm
not okay with that but I know people are
but future presidents will have the
Saville
and if there is no control or discussion
about it then it'll go the way of all
the other things like with the Patriot
Act Adam what do you should the
government be allowed to just show up at
your apartment and drone strike it
without serving you a warrant or at
least a hot meal I would like to believe
that they're not just gonna take out
like 30 people at a time on targeting
one person yeah and in my apartment I
don't think that Obama's like Oh get it
I don't think they're gonna give me that
no one's gonna be that careless is what
I think I don't you know but should they
be able to add guys they were able to
just get that one person and drone them
out and kill them and sure why not all
right we're not big on civil liberties
here but they're very old-school you
know I don't mean personal liberty and
all that all right let's move on to
something far more important than the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights and
all that good stuff soda and sugary
drinks New York City Mike Bloomberg this
week was about to have his wish come
true which was that they were not going
to be allowed to serve sodas over 16
ounces in restaurants in stores bodegas
that whole thing and then at the last
second a judge jumped in and stopped him
said this is not legal
and now Americans can all continue our
right to be fat where do we fall out on
this I'm torn actually cuz like there's
a part of me that one night like there's
a great thing in the in the in the piece
I read earlier nine out of ten
neighborhoods and that were the high had
the highest obesity rates in New York
City also have the largest sale of
sugary drinks so it makes sense that
there's a correlation between sugary
drinks and obesity and it's a huge huge
problem so like yes but at the same time
I really love fresca and now fresco
would be a would not be a part of it but
like I loved soda and I want to be able
to buy it in any form size that I want
at any place because I'm an American
Ohio so you're one example is a soda
that wouldn't have you know like
coca-cola yeah I want to be able to buy
a coca-cola I get that so I'm torn I
don't know
desi what do you think well you know I
understand why Mayor Bloomberg is
because the cost to the states from you
know chronic health impacts of the
obesity crisis that we have you know the
long-term attempts to deal with obesity
and diabetes you know especially in
children the childhood obesity epidemic
this is gonna cost us a lot of money as
a society overall so I understand why
he's doing it it's just I know that this
is the right mechanism for it there's so
many loopholes into it you know it has
to depend on on what the New York City
has authority over and there are some
places that they don't have authority
over so it's a really gonna be a
mishmash of how they enforce it on to
the other jury yeah you know contents of
the drink is Starbucks I I saw that at
one point Starbucks was saying well are
we gonna be including on this was saying
they weren't gonna do it they have the
money to fight it perhaps but now at
least for now they don't do that Adam
you are a fit man looking at tribe
guessing you don't drink a lot of sugary
drink no I think that if it wasn't for
like fat girls then I'd have a much
tougher time in college you know and can
you just lay that logic out again I
think that look the fat girls have a
very good purpose in life I mean there
are good people in general but sometimes
you like your girlfriend dumps you you
need to get some ass quickly yes
normally like you need to get some put
some head you know like fat girls are
known to give really good head and so so
that's one of those things were
something you need fat people look when
I pull up to a fat person I go hey where
should I eat and he points to the
restaurant I know that Curtis person's
gonna know what's a good restaurant is
never like that when I pull up to with
that person as if they're just standing
on the street corner they say never
never trust a skinny chef right you've
heard that you know I mean how are we
gonna know what food tastes good
although you do make several good points
there Adam I think cuz you hit on what I
thought was the most important part here
although I haven't pulled up to a fat
woman lately
the idea
that the that because of now Obamacare
let's say for example we're all in this
together we're all paying taxes into the
system that's going to give us health
insurance so if the person next to you
is eating poorly you're going to end up
paying for their health care so doesn't
that give us all the reason to back
things like this even if it doesn't seem
like it adds up yes I think that because
I mean another good point that the law
makes is that the the largest portion of
people who are obese in America are
people who are either in middle class or
lower middle class or poor and these are
the people who are they're forced to buy
I mean a child after school has a choice
of buying a coca-cola or an apple juice
that costs $2 or a coke can that cost $1
they're gonna choose the thing that cost
a dollar and so they're getting obese
from that and because we're paying in
with Obamacare into the system we're
paying for that child's own obesity 20
20 years down the line I drink a lot of
soda I eat like [ __ ] but I work out and
I go to the gym and I try to run as much
as I can that's really the problem I
think is I think that the soda isn't the
kids are gonna drink too so answer or
three sodas you're gonna buy more soda
it's not they're not gonna withhold from
solar because it's 20 ounce versus a 16
ounce or a 14 ounce so that's again it's
that mechanism you know is this the
right mechanism for it you know when you
say that we pay into the system for
chronic health impacts we also pay into
the system for farm subsidies you know
we have this corn crop that is pervasive
throughout everything we eat every bit
of processed food and the meat that we
eat is raised on corn as well which is
completely unnatural to what they
evolved just for people that aren't
exactly sure what you're talking about
there's high fructose corn syrup
fructose fructose which one is it I
chose okay I did it last week - there's
corn in our soda people don't realize
you have a soda that's right you're
drinking corn that is crazy that's not a
question that's quite healthy this is a
great crop corn is a fabulous crop it
does all kinds of great things but it
the corn system that we have is the
problem there's a great article in The
Economist right now that discusses the
corn system how the subsidies that we
use and the crop insurance program and
various other policies throughout the
Department of Agriculture and of course
big biotech companies like Monsanto you
know they all pay their lobbyists to
make sure they get the kinds of policies
that will benefit their product the most
and so you find here with this New York
soda ban that the beverage industry is a
major fighter for this obviously because
that's their business model so they
would fight it and when you're somebody
like a kid in New York City who only has
a dollar to spend you're the coke is
going to cost you less because it's
subsidized by the rest of us yeah thus
proving that everything comes down to
money once again we do have to move on
but just for the record if you're a
overweight chick and you're into Adam
his Twitter handle is right down there
or if you're angry at him his Twitter
handle is also right down there all
right let's talk about Ashley Judd
because perhaps by the time we get this
out she may have announced that she's
running for Congress in Kentucky where
she lived as a child for part of it she
went to University of Kentucky and she'd
be running for the seat that now Mitch
McConnell who's one of the most powerful
congressmen we have and who's also part
human part turtle
he is so she's he's not happy about that
and the ads even though she hasn't
declared have already started coming out
let's take a look at this one you know
what this country really an independent
voice I am committed to President Obama
as Vice President Biden I think he's a
brilliant man he is now able to flower
our as the president I knew her
a leader who knows how to follow someone
who will never forget quite something
from and it just clicked Tennessee is
home I mean it just quest can someone
who knows what's good for us someone
from out of state understand I don't
know about a hillbilly some golf
hillbillies hillbillies hillbillies her
own grandmother says she's a Hollywood
liberal but Israel hope she's actually
judge but an Obama following radical
Hollywood mushroom Jews right at home
here in Tennessee her whole family
thinks she's a Hollywood liberal this is
her grandmother she is not gonna get a
Christmas present this year I'm sure
about that all right so that aired now
again Ashley Judd has not even announced
that she's running that ad was brought
to you by the fine folks over at
Crossroads for America which is Karl
Rove super PAC which I'm pretty sure
lost every election that they got
involved in this past November Adam yes
what do you think about this kind of
Hollywood elitist beat a human turtle I
think that any party that was in the
movie Tooth Fairy doesn't construe as a
Hollywood latest I think you have to
like I mean her last good movie was uh
was it your last kiss the girls I mean
that was fifteen years ago so you really
her star quality isn't even high enough
to I don't think she's a Hollywood
elitist I think she should but I think
that she should be the coach of Kentucky
because she's been at every game I don't
really think that she's had Sheba Quinn
maybe I don't think so I mean based on I
don't think she could win I mean but it
is she's pretty hot desi do you think do
you think that it takes these of course
do you think that it takes these high
profile whether they're not a listers or
whether they are a-listers happen do you
think it takes these high-profile people
to now run because a regular person
really can't even run for office anymore
just because it connections and money
and everything else well a regular
person can run they're just very
unlikely to win especially
at the Senate level I mean right now the
barriers to entry for a regular person
you know you have to have like a ten
thousand dollar filing fee I'm not sure
what it is for Kentucky but usually in
most states at several thousand dollars
and you have to have a whole apparatus
and a petition that shows you have
support you have to basically be able to
prove that you can pay for the TV
commercials so in that respect Ashley
Judd you know who is a very intelligent
woman and has a great resume outside of
her acting career as well I think she
would be able to for it to afford it you
don't you may not know this but she was
actually UN I think is an ambassador or
one of the programs and I'm sorry I
can't remember right now but I love the
fact that she's even talking about this
because you could tell how much the GOP
is freaked out about it well clearly
because this ad is actually about a
month old and still as we tape this
right now she hasn't even officially
jumped in it looks like it could happen
any moment and they're they're already
running ads against her so hey John
where do you funny she beat he went back
she went back to her husband she was
able to take down her husband in double
jeopardy anyone who can do that can take
down Mitch McConnell in the serious part
I will say she I think she is a credible
candidate I think she would be
incredibly credible candidate only
because we've seen real people win big
offices Barack Obama being a great
example of this when he won the US
Senate in Illinois before he gave that
speech he was just a regular state
representative he was a common man who
put was put into circumstances a sex
scandal not his but another candidate
sex scandal that got him to that seat so
he was a regular person that got there
albeit because of circumstances so it is
possible for a regular person to be even
be elected president I think but I I do
think that she we've seen Canada
candidates crazy candidates get elected
Jesse Ventura I'm not comparing her to
Jesse Ventura but there's a great
example of somebody who's kind of a moat
there yeah in a state in a country now
that has Barack Obama as president that
has kind of we're leaning in a unique
direction yeah I think she could easily
sneak in there what also has the name
recognition I mean in Kentucky the judge
family the judges are very popular and
have been for four decades now so I
think she's got the name recognition and
it would be awesome I think to see her
run against Mitch McConnell even if she
didn't have us know
boss chance and he'll because it would
give a chance for the GOP to show just
how anti-woman they still are in the
campaign that they would run against her
absolutely so how important is it to get
rid of this old guard you know we're
talking about McCain earlier but McCain
and Lindsey Graham who now may have an
openly gay guy running against him in
the primary which I think it's fantastic
how important is it to get rid of these
old guys and they're they're not gonna
go away quietly right I don't know I
like Ashley Judd I think she's very Pro
woman and there's a lot of like great
charity work she seems like a very
educated I would vote for her if I look
at Kentucky I'm all about term limits
for even senators senators and Commons
I'm I understand that sometimes
seniority in the Senate in res run on
seniority but I think having someone in
there for 40 years just creates this
establishment that then doesn't get
anything done it create create
situations like well Rand Paul Paul
wasn't part of that Rand Paul's for
anything even for the president I think
that I think if a guy's doing a good job
keep them there I might like a book
little facts you stayed in you know and
then George Bush had I mean imagine I
mean there might not guessing you're not
for term limits I am NOT for term limits
yeah there's some studies that show that
when you put them in place in states
that they actually increase the power of
party bosses because that means that
people have to then move around you know
they're like oh I'm term limited out of
this so that means that the party boss
then has more power over who does get
put up into these primary elections and
then on to what happens in in in the
actual office because people don't have
that institutional memory they don't
remember what happened for and they take
some that much longer to learn the job
before they're actually effective in it
so it's an interesting I think the
problem that you're talking about is
money in politics you know that if we
didn't have the the corruption of money
throughout the campaigns and the
lobbying when you're already when you do
get to elected office that that's where
the issues actually lie in that you know
term limits wouldn't necessarily save
that that's why I'm actually only half
kidding when I say this but I think
politicians should only be allowed to
run once because then they wouldn't
spend the second half of the first time
looking forward to the second point
abling they lost like every election
before he became president I can't argue
against Lincoln that would be all right
we got to move on North Korea Kim
jong-un he is well he wants to a launch
a preemptive nuclear strike on America
he's not happy with us because of some
military stuff going on over there they
just ripped up the truce with South
Korea which I guess means the North
Korean South Korean war is back on so
you know I guess the Korean vets are
gonna be in some trouble what do we
think about this because it seems crazy
like everyone was sort of laughing I was
watching mainstream news row yeah North
Korea is gonna nuke us you know and
everyone's laughing about it but should
we take this kind of stuff seriously Kim
jong-un announcing that we're gonna be a
nuclear war or he's gonna have nuclear
war against the United States it's like
cher announcing she's gonna retire it's
never you know what I mean like we're
never gonna get to that point so I am
fascinated by this man I'm fascinated by
this country and I think they're I
totally am in favor of the sanctions
being put again and I also think it's
really interesting that China is going
along with these UN sanctions which is
telling it was a bear to where the
nuclear material is well yeah but even
then I mean it doesn't it I think China
is even learning as probably because of
money but they're learning that it
doesn't benefit them to keep supporting
this country that they're trying to kill
out this country and the country is
letting themselves die I think I mean
Kim jong-un is killing its people and
China is now realizing we need to
abandon ship on you guys I mean what do
you make of this kind of like
over-the-top rhetoric there obviously
first off they don't have missiles that
they can attach this stuff to so
everyone's saying that best they could
create some sort of you know dirty bomb
situation but what do you think it's
just the rhetoric and the level of you
know saber-rattling typically you know
it's it's discussed as well you know
they're just trying to get more
attention because when they do these
huge threats that you know that's
sabre-rattling like you said that they
actually then get the United States to
come sit down and okay give us some more
a give them some more money help them to
you just basically get the attention
that they want and now that you know Kim
jong-un I think is it is it this I'm
sorry I'm straight that he's actually
trying to cement his position in the
Media at home and abroad as well I think
it's really interesting that China is
getting involved in this it's it's it's
it's really it's it's like a
psychological thriller in a way cuz you
get to find out this crazy guy and why
is he doing this because he knows he can
be wiped off the map
so and ironically and I think this is
what you were alluding to China can't
have us get nuked because then they
wouldn't be able to call in the dead so
I have a feeling that you think that
this has something to do with Dennis
Rodman am i right
I you know I heard that after hanging
out with Robin they're gonna be both on
Celebrity Rehab next year but I'm gonna
say who would have thought that an you
know a Korean guys missile couldn't
reach his destination it's the Twitter
feed hunter the comic atom comedian atom
comedian but I was a big fan of this
guy's music with Gangnam style our
president's hanging out with jay-z and
he's hanging out with Dennis Rodman like
you know we're definitely winning in
this situation in every front Dennis
Rodman what more does he want war I want
to stay well you know what's funny I was
watching Celebrity Apprentice a couple
nights ago and Dennis Rodman is now on
Celebrity Apprentice and despite the
lunatics that he's on that show with
like Gary Busey and the rest of these
overly plastic surgery people he still
comes off as the craziest one and that's
the guy that we sent with the
Globetrotters having like Ron Artest as
a normal one right piece that's how bad
Kobe and Dwight Howard are what do you
guys make of that that we send these
people I mean we literally sent Dennis
Rodman and the Globetrotters to North
Korea to somehow it was very clear that
they did not have anything to do with
this yeah the State Department does one
yeah and like the Globetrotters going to
the Philippines and doing this whole
thing and they were following them
around or something like that and ended
up in Korea I'm not sure exactly but I
know that it was part of an HBO the show
it was money well I guess the point here
is that we're talking about nukes
and yeah Dennis Rodman in the same story
and that's bizarre
I think that North Korea in South Korea
should have a big game of Dance Dance
Revolution
I think
if you go to the arcade it's all Asian
people they're just dancing on that and
I think that that dance diplomacy would
I would love to see Hillary Clinton do
that thank you so much fun I knew you
were gonna get a hello we're cops ago
yeah everyone if a terrorist others on
US soil
the drones I don't mind and that US
citizens droning attacks just to get big
if it was it was a foreign terrorist
hanging out at like Applebee's I
wouldn't mind a drone just [ __ ] with
the definition of combat it precisely
that's why it's who do you leave all
this stuff up to that's where the real
discussion about all this is but we have
to move on Google Glasses people Google
if you're using your cell phone to text
and tweet and make calls that's that's
old school already glasses we're all
gonna be wearing this pair of $1,500
glasses that is gonna record everything
you do and you're gonna be texting from
your glasses and watching videos and
uploading them and downloading them
Google put out a video let's take a look
okay glass record a video
okay glass hang out with the Flying Club
Google photos of Tiger heads
you ready you ready right there
okay glass take a picture
all right so this wonderful video you're
gonna wear these glasses suddenly you'll
want to jump out of a plane and do all
kinds of stuff that you normally
wouldn't do but I really truly believe
this is going to be the worst thing ever
we are going our privacy the little bit
of privacy that we have left is going to
suddenly disappear because everyone you
talk to is going to be recording you at
all times
desi what do you think well actually
when I first read about this the first
thing that popped into my mind is that
that would violate California wiretap
law you are not allowed to videotape
people without their consent and then
post I mean that's the whole thing about
the James O'Keefe hoax videos of ACORN
you know there was a settlement that
that acorn worker got because James well
he wasn't criminally prosecuted he got
immunity to give up the unedited tapes
but that's against the law don't you
think that Google just because of their
money and influence will somehow they're
gonna say it's not video taping it's you
know digitally you'll probably try to
get away with it in some fashion that's
not like they don't have lawyers to do
that or lobbyists but you know it's not
Alan against the law in all states you
know that's specifically what's against
the law in California is that you must
have explicit permission to do so and to
post it so that would be an interesting
legal issue about that but the other
part about that that really gets to me
is that the Google spokesman and the
link that you sent to me she said that
behaviors and social norms will develop
over time I have that quote here I'm
glad you read it okay I'm incredible I
think this is incredible that Google is
saying we're gonna put out something
that is gonna so shift the way we all
act and the way we all behave that
you're just gonna have to join us for
the ride and and you have no choice and
we'll clean up the mess later yeah hm
you're the only one here with glasses so
I you're the expert here so take it away
let's talk to privacy real quick I I
don't mind the idea of somebody taping
me not because I have like attention but
because I feel like that's where we're
going that's not that they're now
they're not commenting on well they
might be commenting on me I don't know
we live in that world now the world is
changing just like when people were
fearing what telephones would do or what
electricity would do this is a part of
that that we shouldn't just be fighting
it you should be acknowledging it
definitely setting up laws that protect
people like the California law but we
should be acknowledging that changes are
happening and then working that into the
system where we feel comfortable in our
democracy I don't think we should just
be saying no to it but I will say the
quote that you read about Google it's
also the owner of the bar said I'm a
thought leader someone that's a weird
question
yeah let's get to that so we jumped
ahead here so there is a bar and where
is he in Seattle where the the bar owner
has already said even though this stuff
isn't even on the market it's not even
coming out to the end of the year the
owner of the bar has said our bar
you know our patrons are here for
privacy not to be recorded we're banning
this this thing that doesn't even exist
we're preemptively banning it everyone's
into preemption these days Adam do you
want these glasses what are you gonna do
with me now I'm usually wearing beer
goggles anyway but yeah but there's a
part of I mean then I was thinking that
like my mind goes to like all right now
my girlfriend's are trying to see if I'm
cheating on her you know having her
friend wear them to like spy on people
you know and then but and then you know
there's a whole thing of like okay let's
say you go to a bar and you hook up with
a chick who's not attractive because
you're drunk
you could Photoshop her the next day in
your head you know oh she was the
hottest girl but now with these glasses
there's no Photoshop but you're actually
gonna see how ugly the person was even
think of what I was doing my research is
incredible what do you think does any of
this stuff make us happier now look I
say this as an addicted tweeter I love
Twitter I'm on it all day but does any
of this make us happier or actually
connect us more we think it's all
connects us there's a difference you're
you're on Twitter because your job is to
be a social commentator and you want
your own TV show and this is your job to
get fans and that's how you want to
spread to the masses you have a reason
to be on Twitter okay there are people
on Twitter all day I'm eating a sandwich
you know look it's nice out I'm going to
bed I mean and those are people who
should not be on Twitter because I mean
not to be a judge but it's like come on
I mean they're just avoiding everything
is there is a whole level of like I
don't care what they go on an Instagram
oh the Instagram I'm looking at people's
food I wouldn't
why do I want to see your lunch I think
it's a part I agree that people
shouldn't be tweeting about their food
I'm definitely against that but I do
think that and this is from a personal
experience but when I was diagnosed with
cancer there's a conversation happening
with people online who are tweeting
about their food then see something like
I'm tweeting about my own situation and
then they're able to connect in a way
that is so far beyond it just being my
job as a writer comedian it's like
they're you're connecting with people on
a dare on a different level
stay with him okay it's a serious thing
but there are people all day long who
were like you and that's it that's all
they wrote is quality you know it's not
really our place to judge that yeah you
just can't write to do yeah they have
the right to do that you just don't have
to look at it yeah about this idea that
is is any of this connecting us more
ultimately whether the people are just
putting out food pictures or they're
saying something really deep and
profound I mean is it actually
connecting us or are we now all going
out to eat and sitting at our phone the
whole time taking pictures of our phone
and we forget who we're talking to yes
and yes actually I think it does connect
us more but it does tend to connect us
to people who are more like-minded and
keeps us in our little silos where we
don't actually interact with other
people so much you know it does keep us
connected with those people you know
keeps me connected with my family I love
that but you know when you get into
these silos you know this is how we get
into the Fox News brain where we have
all these people who studies show you
know know so little about actual facts
in proportion to how much they watch Fox
News right and it's just reinforcing the
same right so you know it can't help it
can also hurt you know it's it's sort of
a two-way street what interests me more
about the Google glass issue is just the
privacy I mean I know we've given up so
much of our privacy already that people
don't know what's happened but over in
the European Union they have much
stronger controls over privacy and your
content and your data and how come
can use that we don't have those
protections here so I think that this is
this I'm glad we're talking about it but
I don't know that we'll be able to talk
about it before abuses begin I'm being
selfish okay there's a comedian if I'm
wearing on stage and I can look at
people's people's faces are sometimes
hilarious they get offended or they're
booing or they're laughing - then go
look what I'm looking at I think that's
pretty cool and net in that regard but
but then there's also like but when
they're all sitting there wearing the
glasses staring at you when tweeting out
every bad joke that's it
but I've been to some cool like orgy
type parties that like that you know
that those would be kind of cool to have
like I mean that's okay I have a pretty
cool life sometimes there are time and I
just come either watches did you blow me
to those parties what do you know this
is the perfect segue to start talking
about porn but before we do that I want
to remind you guys that bonobos calm is
my official outfitter all these fancy
shirts that you guys have been
commenting on I get him over at bonobos
and if you use code TR r20 TR r20 you
get 20% off your first purchase and now
to the porn the European Union they are
they are talking about banning not only
porn what all kinds of you know sort of
quote-unquote offensive material and a
lot of this is coming out of Denmark but
it would it would obviously span all of
the European Union and it's hard to say
what is porn what is offensive who's
gonna decide on all this stuff
I can't start with you Adam because I
know desi who should decide what is
pornography you know they're doing this
because they're actually they say that
they want to protect the image of women
and stop yeah I think they called it and
eliminate gender stereotypes that demean
women like oh really so you're gonna
born
you're gonna born you're gonna ban porn
because it's worked so well in Muslim
countries exactly right you don't get
some of that sexual stuff out it's
fertile ground it's going to increase
their or elevate the status of women in
that society and that's just [ __ ]
yeah do you do you think it's just an
endless slippery slope that no matter
what you do to kind of curtail
pornography or offensive images that
automatically
nothing good can come out of this
because you just keep going well I think
that the definition of pornography is
the problem I mean the US Supreme Court
has tried and they said well you know I
know it when I see it and that was
determined to be not good enough of a
standard really when you think about the
expansion of internet porn for example
so you know I again it's I understand
the idea behind what they're trying to
achieve with this but it's the
absolutely wrong mechanism because
there's no way to understand who's going
to define it how they would legislate it
how they would enforce it you know
there's so many issues that yeah it's a
slippery slope but it's just a also I
think a boondoggle of enforcement
absolutely people yes I'm totally not in
favor of banning of porn in any capacity
so we're gonna be like yes whatever get
rid of the point but I just say that
there are some things like for example
Iceland is the country that's really
leading this charge and Iceland is
taking note from how China bans from
users from visiting certain website I
really want to use the same software
that is not a country we should be
following no people should ever be
emulating ever China and then on top of
that the country or the party that is
supporting or is against the ban of porn
is the pirate party from Sweden like how
ridiculous
yeah there's it how could anyone take
anybody serious no wonder Europe's in
such I'm a Pirates are horn well but we
could call the pirate party called the
pirate party that's ridiculous Iceland
Iceland is the is the shrinkage there
that was I was a new joke about
shrinkage but I'm not gonna do that now
because yeah did the discharge I'm gonna
go intellectual with you on this one
what do you think that maybe the
European Union is actually too big
because the people the sexual hang-ups
they may have in France may be very
different from the ones they may have in
Belgium or in Iceland etc etc so that
maybe you can't legislate for this giant
no hey you know what I will have to take
together like I think that obviously you
know porn there's a market for it it
doesn't sometimes people people need it
it's a release it's a fantasy it is what
it is but there is a certain element
where there is a dark dark dark element
of porn where like it's like you know
teenage kids you know Bob or bondage or
girls getting [ __ ] on or whatever and
like that I think that that might make
it a point here
that might be too much there is there is
an element of like okay it becomes less
artistic and more just like and then you
have to be careful with that you know
one across is the legal line not illegal
I mean of course underage is illegal but
if someone wants to get [ __ ] on they
have the right as a citizen of at least
the United States to make a film so I
think it should be the same in the
European Union I do agree it shouldn't
be European Union but if if the goal is
to protect the children then and just
don't keep the kids out of court right
don't but don't do it for my children
there is an but like there is underage
porn
I think obviously that's no one you know
and that's if that's the goal then to
get rid of the underage porn but I don't
do you know let's get a little bit back
to what the the purpose supposedly of
this bill is which is to protect the
image of women do you think that porn
actually contributes to negative images
she's the one who was a lot of girls
like don't move to Europe that's first
of all European porn is the craziest
point out there oh yeah like no I
actually have a friend who does porn is
german porn is the one area of porn that
porn actors in the US will never ever go
to it's like they are crazy they do more
than just [ __ ] on Wow so maybe as an
American here I've been watching such
vanilla stuff that I really can't
comment
desi you did not we were know you were
signing up yeah I can see where it's
coming from I watch porn before I mean I
I've seen I know what the psychologists
are talking about when they say that it
demeans women and exploits women I'm
just gonna go I would like to make that
one psychologist that I read
specifically referring to this she said
you know porn is a result of gender
stereotypes it is not the cause of
gender stereotypes so that's gonna be
that will not have the effect that
they're hoping for have the morning I
like the watches like the dancing bear
you see that like a guy comes in dressed
up as a bear he's a stripper and like
all these chicks are just taking turns
on him as a like to me that's that's
that's pro-woman
you know that's all I
I don't know if it's pro-woman it does
but so does so many things in our
society and that's part of the problem
like you said before but it's it starts
with porn becomes from sort of
stereotypes it's not creating more
stereo this conversation any further and
then people start clicking over to porn
I want to thank my guests Adam hunter
desi do an H Alan Scott and I'm gonna
let you guys pimp yourselves out because
I find the guests are much better than
that they get to talk about themselves
hm where can people find it you can find
me on Twitter at H Allen Scott and if
you're in Los Angeles on March 28th you
can see me a kissed at meltdown comics
on communication live I am the co-host
and managing editor of the green news
reports radio progressive show on energy
and environment you can find me on
Twitter at green news report and on the
web at green news brad blog.com adam
adam comedian on twitter if you're a UFC
Fan mmm a roasted Adam hunter comedy
shows every day of the week and then I
have a podcast on the sideshow network
called jokes and jokes and another one
called Adam hunters world so I have two
podcasts going up all right well we did
a little of everything here we talked
about old politicians we talked about
new technology and of course we talked a
little porn I thank you guys for
watching and we got a lot to talk about
when the camera shut off so we'll see
you next week
you